E
ARE REALLY HAPPY AND PROUD OF
YOURSELVES.
GERALDO, THANK YOU,
CHARLIE HURT, THANK YOU.
ALSO TONIGHT, YET MORE
BEWILDERING BLUNDERS FROM, YES,
THE OFTEN GIGGLING
VICE PRESIDENT MOLLY HARRIS, WHO
WANTS TO LET US KNOW SHE REALLY
LIKES THE INTERNET.
I MEAN REALLY LIKES IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Vice President Harris:
CONTEXT THE INTERNET IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF LIFE IN THE
21ST CENTURY.
CAN'T GET AROUND IT.
CAN'T GET AROUND WITHOUT IT.
>> Sean: BIDEN, KAMALA, AND
NANCY PELOSI.
GOD HELP US.
ALL RIGHT.
DESPITE NOT YET COMPLETE IN ANY
OF HER OTHER JOBS, SECURING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS NOW GIVING THE VICE PRESIDENT
MORE RESPONSE ABILITIES.
NOW HEADING UP SOMETHING CALLED
AN ONLINE POLICY TASK FORCE,
WHATEVER THE HELL THAT MEANS.
YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING, WHAT
EXACTLY THAT TASK FORCE WILL DO.
WELCOME AT THIS POINT IT SEEMS
TO BE ANYBODY'S GUESS, EVEN
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
DOESN'T APPEAR TO KNOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
LEADING, GETTING KICKED OFF
TODAY, ON A BACKGROUND CALL LAST
NIGHT WE WERE TOLD IT'S GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT FROM THE
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD
AND THAT IT'S GOING TO FOCUS ON
ILLEGAL CONDUCT ONLINE, BUT THE
MEMO CREATING IT WAS OVER LITTLE
BIT BROADER AND MENTIONS,
QUOTING FROM A DOCUMENT, "ONLINE
HARASSMENT, ABUSE AND
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS
TARGETING WOMEN AND LGBTQ I PLUS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PUBLIC AND
LYTIC FIGURES."
CAN YOU CLEAR UP THE
DISINFORMATION CHARGE?
I WOULD NEED TO TALK TO OUR
TEAM.
I WAS OUT OF THE BACK ON CALL,
SO THAT SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT
YOU'RE PROVIDING TO ME I WOULD
JUST HAVE TO CHECK IN WITH.
>> Sean: IN OTHER WORDS, I
DON'T KNOW A THING ABOUT IT
EITHER.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
PRESIDENT OF CANADA, DEMOCRAT,
SUMMON TULSI GABBARD IS WITH US.
ALL RIGHT.
I WOULD LIKE AMERICA TO GO BACK
TO THE TRUMP POLICIES AND SECURE
OUR BORDER.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO BACK TO THE
POLICIES THAT AMERICA IS ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND STOP SUCKING UP
TO IRAN, VENEZUELA, OPEC, AND
SAUDI ARABIA.
I WOULD LIKE LOWER TAXES, NOT
HIGHER TAXES, LESS BUREAUCRACY,
NOT MORE BUREAUCRACY.
YOUR DEMOCRAT.
DO YOU DISAGREE WITH ANY OF MY
PLANS, THINGS I WOULD LIKE TO
DO?
>> [LAUGHS]
WE SHOULD HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT EACH OF THOSE THINGS,
SEAN.
WE PROBABLY AGREE ON SOME,
DISAGREE ON OTHERS.
IT
>> Sean: HERE'S ONE --
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> Sean: ENFORCE THE LAWS OF
THE BORDER, LET'S GO THROUGH
THEM ONE BY ONE GREAT
>> OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
>> Sean: SO WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
OPEN BORDERS, WE SHOULD GO BACK
THE TRUMP POLICIES, YOU BE OKAY
WITH THAT?
>> I'VE BEEN VERY VOCAL ABOUT
THAT, OPEN BORDERS ARE A THREAT
TO OUR HOME AND SECURITY IN WITH
OPEN BORDERS WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE A COUNTRY.
>> Sean: OKAY, WE HAVE A 41
YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION AND
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES.
NOW, WE CAN FINISH THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE VERY
QUICKLY AND EVERY DAY WE WILL
GET 900,000 BARRELS OF CANADIAN
OIL RIGHT INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
WOULD YOU GO FORWARD WITH THAT?
AND WOULD YOU LIFT THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT JOE BIDEN PUT
ON AND FEDERAL LEASES FOR
FRACKING AND OIL?
WOULD YOU JOIN ME IN THAT?
>> I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO A
PLAN THAT ENSURES OUR ENERGY
SECURITY THAT SECURES THE
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: YOU'RE KIND OF
DOCKING A LITTLE BIT.
I'M ASKING SPECIFICALLY,
KEYSTONE PIPELINE YOU ARE IN
FAVOR OF?
>> WHETHER IT'S THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE OR OTHER RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY --
>> Sean: YOU SUPPORT --
>> ENERGY SECURITY AND DONE SO
IN A WAY THAT'S RESPONSIBLE AND
NOT CONTAMINATED WATER AS
FRACKING HAS DONE IN CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK A
QUESTION, WOULD YOU REMOVE THE
RESTRICTIONS AND REGULATIONS
THAT JOE BIDEN PUT ON THE ENERGY
SECTOR?
AND THAT MEANS ALLOWING MORE
LEASES TO BE GIVEN TO OIL AND
GAS COMPANIES ON FEDERAL LANDS,
THAT WOULD FINISH THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE, REOPEN --
AND ALLOW THESE COMPANIES TO DO
WHAT THEY DO BEST, THAT'S
PRODUCE THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE
WORLD'S ECONOMY.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT ME IN THAT
EFFORT?
>> I SUPPORT YOU AND AGREE WITH
YOU IN ENERGY SECURITY.
I DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY
CHAPTER AND VERSE ALL THE
REGULATIONS AND RESTRICTIONS
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS PUT IN PLACE,
BUT I CAN SAY BROADLY HE HAS PUT
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE THAT HAVE
INHIBITED OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THE ENERGY THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED, ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS CRITICAL TIME.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, LET ME ASK
YOU THIS, BECAUSE JOE IS NOW
APPARENTLY NEGOTIATING A NEW
DEAL WITH IRAN.
HE SENT EMISSARIES ACCORDING TO
REPORTS TO VENEZUELA.
HE'S GOING TO MEET WITH THE
NATION HE CALLED A PARIAH NATION
AND A CROWN PRINCE THAT HE
ACCUSED OF BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DEATH OF JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
WOULDN'T IT BE BETTER FOR OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, FOR JOB
CREATION, TO HELP REDUCE THE
PRICE AT THE PUMP AND HELP
REDUCE INFLATION IF WE AGAIN
BECAME ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND
INSTEAD OF ARTIFICIALLY REDUCING
THE WORLD'S SUPPLY OF OIL,
INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF OIL,
WOULDN'T THAT DRIVE DOWN PRICES?
AND WOULDN'T THAT ALSO DRIVE
DOWN INFLATION?
>> IT WOULD.
>> Sean: SO YOU SHOULD ELECT
ME PRESIDENT, I SHOULD RUN.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Sean: HERE'S THE MAIN
QUESTION, THAT'S WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO GET TO.
YOUR PARTY REFUSES TO LOOK AT
THE DAMAGE THEY'VE DONE A SHIFT
COURSE.
WHY?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
ANSWER QUESTION FOR JOE BIDEN,
KAMALA HARRIS, AND THE LEADERS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU AND I HAVE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS PARTY IS
UNFORTUNATELY TAKING OUR COUNTRY
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
AND THIS LATEST INITIATIVE OF
THIS ONLINE POLICY TASK FORCE IS
JUST YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THEIR SELF-SERVING AMBITION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
STAND GUARD, BECAUSE THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO UNDERMINE OUR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, AND WE CANNOT
ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT, BECAUSE
THAT WILL BRING TRUE DARKNESS TO
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Sean: WE ARE GETTING PRETTY
DARK RIG